une étude flash menée fin octobre par le
professeur delfraissy le président du
conseil scientifique révéler carli sur
cinq étaient fermés dans les hôpitaux
alors que la cinquième vague inquiète et
que le premier ministre est placé à
l'isolément le gouvernement comme
inutile correctement autour du conte
vite 19 on attend vos réactions sur le
pont de télégrammes d'arreter france
tout de suite place au décryptage
[Musique]
et sur ce plateau eric alauzet bonsoir
vous êtes député sur la république en
marche du doubs alexis poulain est
également présent éditorialistes rt
france et puis bruno m'égare ban est
avec nous également un petit peu un
petit peu plus loin en attend une
meilleure connexion pour pouvoir la voir
il est la renault mégane bonjour vous
êtes le chef du service réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
merci messieurs d'être présent pour
parler donc de cette cinquième vague je
commence avec vous et eric alauzet
christophe c'est sur le compte
télégramme daté france dit ceci je cite
ils savent bien communiquer quand il
s'agit de restriction pour les français
mais d'après l'actualité on constate
bien qu'elle ne concerne pas l'exécutif
ceux des spectateurs fait évidemment
allusion je pense à jean castex qui
était placé à l'isolément qu'est ce que
vous voulez lui répondre à christoph
c'est l'exécutif déjà il prône surtout
la vaccination complète la troisième
dose avec des tranches d'âge qui le qui
s'élargissent et ici comme si il le fait
aussi pour lui-même donc l'essentiel le
gouvernement et les personnes
responsables font c'est la vaccination
après le problème moi j'ai moi même
remarqué depuis un certain nombre de
semaines et je m'en désole un
relâchement général des gestes barrières
au motif qu on est vacciné j'ai
participé ces trois derniers jours à
deux réunions avec 300 personnes dans
une salle où tout le monde était
démasqué à je trouve ça pas normal
parfois on se masque pendant la réunion
la réunion il ya donc est ce que le
gouvernement communique c'est justement
pour dire il faut pas abandonner will
try me voyais bien comme c'est au
contact on a tous déjà on a tous envie
de reprendre une vie normale on arrête
tous envie de laisser tomber le masque
de serrer la main de se serrer dans les
bras et c'est bon et les ministres ils
sont en contact permanent tout au long
de la journée avec des tas de personnes
et ils ont ils ont ils sont comme des
autres série zorro parfois aussi baby
vont pas forcément le basque il serre la
main parfois il décide de checker moi je
me suis trouvé dans une réunion d'élus
de mer où j'ai checké dix fois j'ai
abandonné au bout de dix fois tout le
monde le savait hélas et quand je prends
des points dès gens de scène entouré le
point avec la main j'ai fini par se fait
la main comme tout le monde donc c'est
très très difficile on a tous envie de
reprendre une vie normale et puis tout
le monde s'est relâché disons le tout le
monde s'est relâchée vous constatez
abdul rahman vous constatez se relâchent
membres nommés garbani on
cale osé parler du vaccin qui est
important n'est perdu pour nommer gabon
alors on va repartir avec avec avec
alexis poulain vous êtes là
on a retrouvé bruno meyer ban on vous
entend c'est déjà ça
par rapport au feu
ou par rapport je vous confirme tout à
fait effectivement il y à bien
relâchement des mesures barrières
partout dans la société
dans dans les entreprises ou des
réunions dans les casses et dans les
restaurants et lieux de loisirs
malheureusement effectivement on habitue
à la suite d'un quatrième bague unis
sont définitivement débarrassé
ça n'est pas le cas nous l'avions
bergman signalé le virus disparaîtra
maintenant c'est vrai que le vase nous
nous attendions comme étant plus
performant pour protéger contre l'état
nation s'est avéré un tout petit peu
moins six passes à ce niveau est ce que
vous attendez demain du conseil de
défense sanitaire jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui a tweeté vacciner ne règle
pas tout vous attendez par exemple que
les tests redeviennent gratuit
alors nous espérons que un changement du
pass sanitaires et le pass vaccinale
avec peut-être comme corollaire le
remboursement à nouveau des tests
virologiques pour permettre à tous de se
dépister car on voit aujourd'hui être
contact devient très fréquents je crois
qu'il ya une partie de la population qui
a peur de devoir débourser de l'argent
pour ces tests et qui malheureusement
même contact ne se dépistent pas et peut
contribuer à propager le virus par
ailleurs évidemment on attend on va dire
une annonce ou mieux encourager la
vaccination millions de personnes encore
non vaccinés et enfin très probablement
une extension
de la population éligible voici
40 ans
justement c'était la question m'a tendu
la perche pour nommer germann la haute
autorité de santé on l'avait également
avec katia technique 1 devant le
ministère de la santé préconise une dose
de rappel pour les plus de 40 ans mais
est ce que cette dose de rappel va être
élargi pour tous les adultes selon vous
c'est peut-être ce qui peut être annoncé
demain au conseil de défense des revenus
de communication que va dire le
gouvernement ben je pense oui puisque
apparemment on a suffisamment de doses 1
deux heures au moins pour cette
troisième dose et qu'apparemment elle
booste un pour l'hiver au moins les
défenses immunitaires après sur le temps
long on verra comme pour les premières
doses et les deuxième dose ce qu'il en
est sur le long terme puisque on avance
à vue en réalité un ce vaccin on est en
train de découvrir qui marche moins bien
que ce qui avait été proposé ou annoncé
un parent fighters 95 % de d'efficacité
contre le virus on voit bien que
vacciner on attrape le coc vide on le
transmet également donc évidemment ça
commence à poser des questions alors on
fait des formes moins grave mais on voit
et qui fait plus il ya de vacciner plus
il ya de gens doublement vaccinés avec
un schéma complet qui se retrouve à
l'hôpital quand même donc ça pose la
question si de de cette efficacité
finalement et d'où la question des
gestes barrières on peut pas et la
communication du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'il ya un bug c'est que d'un côté
on a le premier ministre les ministres
qui expliquent doctement qu'il faut
respecter les gestes barrière y compris
à la maison les masques etc et puis on
voit les vidéos du chef de l'état à
faire la fête après le match de foot
caritatif embrassant tout le monde on
voit jean castex au salon des maires
pareil serrant la main de tout le monde
et les français ne comprennent pas ils
se disent alors attendez d'un côté on
doit faire obéir à des injonctions
contradictoires et de l'autre côté ceux
qui nous imposent les confinements ce
qui nous impose des gestes barrières
bien finalement s'en fichent totalement
et elle le montre avec un grand sourire
ça peut pas fonctionner avec cette
communication là il ya un nouvel exemple
par rapport à ça je me tourne vers vous
et un call aux airs il ya aussi la
clément bonin secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes qui a
retiré sa photo d'instagram sur laquelle
il posait avec avec jean castex sans
masque c'est quoi c'est faites ce que je
dis ne faites pas ce que je fais comme
dit enfin je crois que la situation est
suffisamment inquiétante même si avec le
vaccin on peut être un petit peu rassuré
pour qu'on aille pas trop se perdre dans
les anecdotes pardon mais je crois que
l'essentiel c'est vraiment d'appeler nos
concitoyens avec les réserves vous avez
raison de dire que le bac c'est un petit
peu moins efficace que ce qu'on a dit il
reste toutefois très efficace il ya le
rapport est de 1 à 10 entre les
personnes dax idées et non vaccinés dans
les entrées en à l'hôpital et en soins
critiques en réanimation et avec la
troisième dose c'est même de 1 à 30 donc
il faut vraiment exhorté nos concitoyens
à aller se vacciner puisque vous êtes
dans l'anecdote j'ai entendu aussi le
cas de cette famille vosgienne où
aujourd'hui où les trois personnes non
vaccinées sont décédées trois personnes
dans un village de noyers quasiment
personne avec les comorbidités alors
après aussi l'une des deux premières
très âgées donc par nature fragile et le
troisième est qu'une comme un mythe
comme how it comorbidités enfin battre
malgré tout on se dit mais quel gâchis
alors qu'on a qu'on a un vaccin quoi ça
me fait de la peine de voir tous ces
gens qui sont influencés par tous ceux
qui à la moindre occasion y compris la
réflexion vous avez rapporté de jean luc
mélenchon l'instant à chaque occasion
c'est l'occasion de jeter le doute sur
la vaccination bien sûr que la
vaccination ne fait pas tout mais elle
fait l'essentiel il faut le dire et le
redire et les courbes sont claires quand
on compare les pays dans les pays les
plus vaccinée c'est là qu'on a le moins
de décès rapportés à la moyenne de
population bien entendu on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans les territoires outre
mer et les îles du pacifique voilà donc
c'est clair et il faut pas que de doute
là-dessus et vraiment c'est des gens les
plus fragiles gros sel mêlée française
pose quand même des questions et
regardez par exemple nathalie leur comme
c'est faites ce que je dis faites pas ce
que je fais normes et personne n'est
infaillible et je voulais dis moi moi
moi même je de pourtant je suis marié
j'ai même ne masque sur votre plateau
j'essaie d'avoir le faudra posséder les
distances mardi avant moi et moi même
des moments je craque comme je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure quand tout
le monde veut me serrer la main que je
tourne toi est comme saisi la main qui
secoue les jeux face à beaune et j'ai
envie de masques et j'ai serré la main
et donc si on prend en photo à ce moment
là eh ben on va voir je serre la main
mais je crois pas que ça doit parce
qu'on est tous ces petits éléments là si
on les rabâchant groupe et bien c'est
les gens qui sont les plus éloignés de
la formation qui sont souvent les plus
pauvres les plus isolées ils vont
attendre c'est son cloche qui vont dire
regardez ils sont pas d'accord entre eux
mais vous connectant sur la libye
fication qu' il ya un tel raz le bol une
telle lassitude parce que le vaccin
était vendu comme la fin du masque la
fin des gestes barrières rappelez-vous
les mots de jean castex ce qu'ils
disaient si vous êtes doublement
vaccinez vous notre après deux pâles
copies dont il est malade ce soir on lui
souhaite un bon rétablissement mais il
ya eu tellement de ratés dans la
communication c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois on promettait une libération un
retour à la vie d'avant et aujourd'hui
on a le vaccin les gestes barrière le
masque et on sais pas qu'est ce qu'on va
avoir d'autres peut-être le retour un
conte fini ce doit être un couvre-feu
c'est à dire que les français n'en
peuvent plus en réalité la 6ème tout
fait pour s'en sortir et on n'en sort
pas ce que vous imaginez la situation
dans laquelle on serait si on n'avait
pas eu accès ce serait dramatique on
serait en confinement permanent
l'économie serait effondré il y aurait
des détresses psychologiques et sociales
ce serait terrible sonel déjà des
détresses de miss belgique et sociales
seraient remy julie ferrier se seraient
multipliés à l'infini donc on a eu cette
chance ils espéraient d'abord al aqsa et
on peut donner de l'espoir aux français
en souvient cette époque-là de l'année
là mais l'année dernière l'année
dernière il y avait trois sets et
olivier ferrand qui disait par rapport à
la bûche de noël on va devoir la manger
peut-être à distance ou quelque chose
dans et dans le civil par rapport à la
bûche de noël voyez bien pouvoir semble
reconnaissez que au nom d'al de
l'information et de la connaissance qui
s'accumulent au fur et à mesure du temps
faire à mesure qu'on constate ce qui se
passe au début on ne savait pas que le
vaccin fonctionnerait six mois on s'aime
on se doutait qu'il allait fonctionner
qu un certain temps on ne fait pas la
bosse de boutiques et les gens qui
demandaient un peu plus de recul et on
se dit maintenant regardez il ya
suffisamment de recul et on voit bien
que le recul on en train de le faire on
a ri 106,6 demandé le recul pour
attendre de faire la vaccination
dire qu'il ya certains vaccins qui
maintenant sont déconseillés pour les
moins de 30 ans que l'on soit modern art
délicat ils sont issus des agrafes d'avc
ils sont non non non ils sont suspendus
pour l'émail est conseillée elle à son
étendue vous savez on est revenu sur
astrazeneca on arrêtait à travers les
cas au motif qu'ils avaient des
phlébites des ordures etc les anglais
ont vacciné toute leur population avec
astrazeneca vie avec à beaucoup
n'avaient pas grave avec pas plus de
problèmes vasculaires thromboemboliques
que chez nous moi je regrette qu'on
l'arrêté l'émotion était telle qu'il
fallait l'arrêter la précaution nous a
poussé à l'extrême de l'arrêter
heureusement maintenant on a fait des
études avec le recul on sait qu'il ya
pas plus dans bunyetes d'accidents
cardiovasculaires c'est en fait
quelques-unes quand même malheureusement
oui il pas plus que dans la population
normale c'est une chance qu'il y avait
les yeux messieurs venant sur marché
depuis plus longtemps non non non
transformé gardanne il est issu il est
là juste devant le professeur médias ban
vous avez peut-être envie de réagir à ce
qui vient de se dire là sur le plateau
oui non je suis tout à fait d'accord ce
qui vient d'être dit effectivement si
nous avions pas le vaccin nous serions
aujourd'hui dans une situation
de gravité extrême lui quasiment aucune
activité sociale économique ou aurait pu
avoir lieu les écoles les universités
ont été fermées les hôpitaux ont été
submergées le tour était bien
je me permet de redonner encore cette
anecdote un jean castex sq a reçu deux
doses de vaccin
mais il est positif le vaccin qui
protège le hand c'est contre les cas
graves on espère qu'il va bien se porter
évidemment mais il ya quand même pas
c'est pas un petit peu démoralisant tout
ça on se vaccine on est quand même
vacciner
c'est quand la fin de tout ça dans dix
ans comme disait par exemple votre
confrère jelly annan
en début d'année dernière je crois le
chef de réanimation à l'hôpital de
garches
alors si vous voulez le virus existera
sur la planète il y aura toujours un
réservoir humain non immunisés n'est
vacciné et surtout un réservoir animal
mais avec l'augmentation d'immunité
collective de la population et bien au
fur et à mesure des contaminations
l'infection deviendra de plus en plus
mignonne et donc effectivement on va
associer très bientôt je ne sais pas
dans quel délai
parce que ce virus devienne responsable
d'une maladie
respiratoire
banal hivernale mais en attendant il y a
encore aisément la moitié de la planète
qui n'est pas maxime et de ce fait
évidemment il ya une menace directe
touristique et non vaccinés à faire des
formes graves de la maladie a empêché à
grasse on va dire garantir la scène
placements à haut niveau du virus et
donc malheureusement au risque
d'émergence de paris la commission
européenne a ajouté un tableau avec des
données disant que plus le taux de
vaccination est élevé plus la mortalité
est faible eric alauzet on le voit la ce
ce tableau au niveau de votre
communication sein de votre parti
présidentiel comment convaincre
justement les non vaccinés en projetant
le tableau que vous êtes vous même en
train de projeter à l'instant je sais
pas s'il est visible sur l'écran pour
tes les édiles blatter c'est flagrant
vous voyez bien à gauche plus vous êtes
en haut à gauche en bleu plus vous êtes
vacciné dans les pays et en bas quand ça
devient rouge est peu vaccinés et vous
avez à droite la colonne alors je ne
sais pas si c'est des gens en
hospitalisation en réanimation je vois
pas bien en tout cas on voit bien que
dans les pays non vaccinés en bas à
gauche fascine vers signer à droite les
morts et donc on voit bien dans les pays
peu vaccinés en bas de l'échelle
le nombre de morts rapporté à la même
unité de population ainsi n'en savons
rien et voilà eh bien il faut projeter
sa faut mettre matin midi et soir mais
d'un autre côté il ya aussi le côté on
va dire liberticide entre guillemets je
vous propose de regarder cette
déclaration sur le conte télégramme de
darty france delphine qui dit prendre en
otage les gens et détruire la liberté ce
n'est pas communiqué alexis poulains
n'ont cessé pas gouverner non plus c'est
à dire que on a vu une gestion
extrêmement autoritaire et seulement
sécuritaire la société de vigilance
c'est pas rien c'est la vigilance de la
technopolis on a vu la loi sécurité
globale qui était en même temps que le
coc vide derrière c'est pas du tout des
mesures sanitaires le fait que les tests
ne soient pas remboursés par exemple
c'est une mesure non sanitaires
j'attendais demain ce que le
gouvernement communique là dessus pour
en rendre les tests gratuits une chose
importante est nécessaire je pense si on
veut être sérieux avec la limitation de
la propagation du virus et puis la
deuxième question qui se plaindrait les
finances la nécessité aussi la finance
de toute façon on trouve de l'argent
magique quand il ya besoin là dessus il
n'y a pas de problème donc vu qu'on est
en crise qu'on est en état d'urgence
permanent qu'on a une dette qu'ovide qui
est cataclysmiques que le sénat vient de
retoquer de budget je pense qu'on peut
trouver de l'argent pour des tests mais
la question qui se pose fondamental
c'est celle du pass sanitaires si les
vaccinés sont contaminants et se
contaminent à quoi sert le pass sa
victoire à quoi sert le pass annie terre
aujourd'hui puisque on a une population
vaccinée à plus de 76% chez les adultes
certaines tranches d'âge a plus de 80%
le pass sanitaire qui est son but sans
le dire c'était d'inciter les français à
la vaccination c'est fait maintenant il
faut inciter à la troisième dose on va
garder le pas salutaire pour la
quatrième dose également s'ils font une
quatrième dose tous les 6 mois comment
ça se passe le pass sanitaires
maintenant il n'a plus aucune raison
d'être alors soit on met un couvre-feu
on referme les lieux de sociabilité
comme les restaurants etc et on repart
dans ce délire là avec les commerçants
pour l'essentiel soit on arrête son dit
voilà c'est fait on a réussi maintenant
on va un peu lâché la soupape parce que
les français n'en peuvent plus
clairement en tout cas dans les autres
pays renvoyant à le voir un petit peu
plus tard
je dois payer non mais si puisque en
guadeloupe déjà ils ont décalé
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
autres en terre et maintenant les tests
sont revenus des tests gratuits sont
revenus donc de toutes façons vous voyez
bien que si sa gueule à un moment le
gouvernement oblige et 10 rebonds on va
arrêter avec nos mesure où on enferme
les hamsters dans la cage on les fait
sortir et c'est donc là je crois que
c'est important aussi de comprendre que
le sanitaire doit redevenir au devant de
la scène et le sécuritaire et
autoritaire doit laisser la place voilà
au sanitaire parce que sinon ça ne
tiendra pas sur le long terme votre
réaction eric alauzet sur votre premier
point des libertés sur lequel vous avez
une réaction impulsive moi je considère
que ce sont celles et ceux qui ne se
vaccinent pas qu'ils attentent à la
liberté de la société puisqu'il nous
retarde parfois de bonne foi je certains
ont peur et on peut discuter tout ça
mais en tout cas il nous retarde par le
fait qu'ils encore le 15 pour cent de
gens non vaccinées dans le processus d'
aller de retrouver une vie normale plus
en argent non vaccinés plus on risque d
confinement des des couvre-feux qui vont
atteindre les libertés de tous
les pays la sortie pour cent des îles
avec cinéaste à plus de 100% ou de toute
façon hors confine quand toute la
population française sera vacciné et qui
aura toujours le bienvenu puisque
visiblement séides gibraltar pour
gibraltar et puis on confine et oui il
sort ils sont obligés par serrar 10%
malheureusement les qu'un pays comme
l'islande par exemple qui est très
vacciner où il ya beaucoup de 4 covit
n'y a pas de cas graves une confusion
permanente qui est entretenue entre le
nombre de cas et le nombre des cas
graves si demain pour les raisons qu'on
a indiqué parce que le vu le d'aller
militer collective etc on a toujours
vingt mille trente mille cinquante mille
cas mais que ce sont des cas bénins déco
vide est comme on a des grippes est on
s'en fiche c'est pas le cas de ce nom
c'est pas encore le cas non ce n'est pas
encore le cas mais on va y aller
progressivement versés mais on a encore
besoin pour l'instant de deux coups
voyez alors le deuxième question c'était
le vaccin ne protège pas contre la
contamination on est content amis
pourraient être contaminés et corps
éminent on est passé du noir ou blanc
les choses sont grises en réalité on
n'est pas celle qu'on croyait on
espérait que le vaccin nous protégerait
contre le fait d'être contaminés
contaminants ils nous protègent contre
les animations c'est julien donc non et
maintenant on va dire le contraire le
vaccin ne protège pas contre la
contamination
et le fait d'être contaminés et d'être
contaminants et ben c'est entre les deux
cas sur entre vacciner vacciner avec la
troisième dose qui nous protège beaucoup
plus trente fois plus cinq ans je lisais
1 à 10 entre un non vaccinés quelqu un
qu avec deux doses à 30 en train non
vaccinés quelqu'un qui l'a 3,12
peut-être mais je m'avance donc on verra
peut-être que avec la troisième dose on
est peut-être encore un peu moins
contaminant est contaminée j'ai nommé
carbone vous pouvez peut-être réagi on
arrive à
bruno mais si vous avez beau temps va
peut-être écouter la parole d'invention
j'apprécie beaucoup je l'écouté souvent
sur s i pod chaînes concurrentes en tout
cas je vous écoute et on sait très bien
aussi
je confirme tout à fait les propos de
monsieur le député a tout à fait raison
effectivement heureusement que nous
avons le vaccin ne protège contre les
formes graves de la maladie
est effectivement lorsque les personnes
deviendront éligibles à cette troisième
dose en serait très nettement leur
protection par un facteur au vin
donc c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
on peut même penser que cette protection
va durer beaucoup plus longtemps que six
mois
il est vrai aussi très probablement eu
la contamination va se réunir d'ailleurs
on voit aujourd'hui en israël avec la
stratégie de la troisième dose plus
générale la population est bien l'un des
seuls pays occidentaux où finalement les
contaminations régressent et c'est vrai
que malheureusement on devoir apprendre
à vivre avec le virus à condition
évidemment que l'on soit pro b g et à ce
moment là il y aura pas de problème
c'est ce virus sera assimilable à un
virus responsables d'infections
respiratoires banao d'ailleurs rouge
lointain et 4 au dessus cousin
coronavirus responsables de tels
problèmes merci pour votre votre
décryptage bruno meyer bahn je rappelle
que vous êtes le chef de réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris merci
également à vous messieurs aletti
poulain éditorialistes rt france eric
alauzet député maire m tous merci c